el papel que juegan los maestros en la
creación de una cultura de mentalidad de
crecimiento puede ser tremendamente
poderoso y pueden utilizar una variedad
de estrategias y enfoques diferentes
para hacerlo una de las formas poderosas
en la que los maestros pueden modelar
una mentalidad de crecimiento es tener
una mentalidad de crecimiento de cada
uno de sus estudiantes para creer
fehacientemente y comunicarles que
realmente espera que cada uno de ellos
sea exitoso que con las estrategias
correctas y el esfuerzo adecuado cada
uno de sus estudiantes puede tener éxito
en sus clases y alcanzar niveles
verdaderamente altos igual de importante
es que el maestro les comunique que él
está ahí para apoyarlos durante este
proceso no decirles creo que puedes
hacerlo y buena suerte si no aquí estoy
para ayudarte para asesorarte y para
ayudarte a aprender a crecer y tener
éxito en mi clase
creo que otra estrategia que pueden usar
los maestros para crear una cultura de
mentalidad de crecimiento es enfocarse
en el proceso de aprendizaje no
enfocarse en los resultados ni en las
calificaciones que obtienen los alumnos
sino en el proceso de crecimiento y en
las estrategias que pueden usar para
mejorar su trabajo puede ser realmente
útil y estimulante para los estudiantes
que el maestro señale las cosas
específicas que están haciendo bien les
puede ayudar a construir su capacidad de
defenderse a sí mismos ya ver que en
efecto están creciendo incluso cuando no
obtengan la mejor calificación ahora
para los maestros puede ser un desafío y
una inversión de mucho tiempo revisar
realmente el trabajo que están haciendo
los estudiantes para poder reconocer y
señalar las estrategias correctas pero
en verdad esto rinde frutos ya que
dirige la atención de los estudiantes a
asegurarse de que están usando las
estrategias adecuadas y los ayuda a
entender que el éxito en la disciplina
que sea matemática ciencia literatura
es una combinación de aprender y dominar
estas diferentes estrategias y ellos
verán que están creciendo y que son
reconocidos por sus logros en el camino
de volverse realmente buenos en esa
materia
otra forma que creo que es importante en
la que los maestros pueden modelar la
mentalidad de crecimiento es hablar de
ellos mismos hablar sobre su propia
trayectoria de aprendizaje y la forma en
la que abordaron los errores crear un
ambiente en el cual los errores se
celebran es realmente poderoso un
ambiente en el cual a los estudiantes no
les preocupe cometer errores pues saben
que su maestro no los va a menospreciar
por el contrario si les ponen atención
esos errores son pistas importantes de
lo que podrían hacer para mejorar
incluso algunos maestros cometen errores
a propósito en su propia enseñanza y de
esta manera tienen a los estudiantes
atentos a los errores y pueden modelar
cómo se debería reaccionar cuando se
equivocan por ejemplo cuando los
estudiantes
que un maestro ha cometido un error el
maestro no se pone a la defensiva ante
la equivocación no trata de esconderlo
sino que les agradece por hacer ver su
error y corregirlo les dice pensemos en
por que cometí ese error pensemos en las
estrategias que podría usar para no
volver a cometerlo de esta forma el
maestro está modelando está ofreciendo
el andamiaje mental con el que a la
larga los estudiantes necesitarán
interactuar así que cuando ellos cometan
sus propios errores conocerán la forma
sana de reaccionar ante ellos